is MKBHD still wrong about the s23
taking fake photos he admitted in
yesterday's video that he was wrong but
it seems like he's still sucking up to
Samsung and I'll explain exactly why
giving you guys a lot more detail about
what's happening and why Samsung isn't
being completely honest now with that
I'll give you guys my opinion coming
from a person who loves the iPhone and
if I think Apple should be doing the
same thing just like many other
YouTubers I have been very impressed
with the zoom capabilities with
Samsung's phones going all the way back
to the s20 ultra when they introduced
this telescopic super zoom but it was
the S21 Ultra that absolutely blew our
minds and since that first moonshot
we've been taking shots like these
because it absolutely embarrasses what
Apple does but it turns out we along
with many other people were outright
duped now me doing photography as a
profession for many years was always a
little bit skeptical about the quality
they were getting it's six and a half
it's fake it's CGI yeah but now we know
for sure Reddit user I break photos did
a very clever test to see this now MKBHD
did address this but he skimmed over
some things and I think he made it a
little too nice for Samsung and we
actually have even more details that
were just updated originally the Reddit
user took this high resolution photo of
the Moon he down sampled it's super
small added a bunch of blur and then he
clipped out the highlights to get rid of
that detail here's an upsized version of
that where you don't see anything at all
and then he zoomed in with his phone as
you guys see right here onto the Monitor
and we see all sudden bam there's detail
out of nowhere but what's crazier is
once this photo is processed we get this
moonshot which looks absolutely
incredible like you took a very
expensive DSLR and you attached it to a
telescope to take that photo the before
and after is absolutely startling and
absolutely impossible which is not what
MKBHD said now before I show you guys
the update that the user did first let
me tell you about our partner case coup
their magic stand case combines the best
and most Wanted aspects of a case into
one and they have this brand new frosted
color which is really nice you've not
only got a great and durable design with
strong magsafe magnets built in but the
maxafe ring is literally on a hinge so
you can use it as a finger grip or as a
stand with a huge degree of
adjustability which is perfect for
watching videos and the best part is
that it folds back completely flush with
the case so it doesn't interfere with
any other Maxi Chargers or accessories
so check out the link and all of the
discount info in the video description
below now I have to say that I
appreciate the MKBHD admitted that he
was wrong in saying that there's no
fakery going on and that you should have
tested more but what's weird is even
though he addressed multiple points he
didn't really give a lot of the major
detail now Samsung does have an article
that talks about how they do certain
things and he was saying they don't fake
or overlay anything but going back to
that original article I break photos
address this and how Samsung isn't being
completely honest and that if you do
turn off C Optimizer even after that
fact and blurring out all of that detail
clipping all the highlights with scene
Optimizer off it still is processing a
photo that is downright impossible to do
using Photoshop because that detail is
clearly not there you go from this blob
of mess to something that is slapped on
detail and that is what scene Optimizer
what is doing this turned off he also
added more edits here where he took a
photo that has two moons there one fully
visible that the phone can recognize as
a round object likely the moon and then
another one and after taking that photo
you could see that here at the bottom we
have a moon that has a ton of detail
looks amazing and then the one above
that it didn't recognize of the mood
just being a blurred blob anyways
without that extra detail that was added
so how big of a deal is this really well
Samsung's been doing this for a while
he's the S21 Ultra compared to the 12
Pro Max massive difference but they've
been increasing what is actually
happening with the S21 Ultra another
user took some images here and he showed
how much detail was added just taking a
photo of his monitors couple years ago
but then he took a smiley face and added
it where it clearly shows completely
gray no texture and then that texture
was turned into things that look like
craters basically things that are
slapped on detail that's not actually
there not being enhanced so while MKBHD
doesn't seem to phase about it and he's
trying to be nice to the brands which
makes sense a lot of people are upset
especially when Samsung is pushing
advertising like crazy literally making
fun of telescopes and showing off their
phone being able to take amazing shots
of the Moon and it's not only in that
one ad it is in a bunch of ads showing
space
showing the capabilities when in fact a
lot of that is fake and it's added on AI
detail now how upset am I obviously I'm
an iPhone fan and obviously we've showed
off many shots where the iPhone gets
killed with these kind of shots and they
now know why but to be completely honest
in this day and age where a lot of
images have a lot of processing and they
do look more like what our eyes have
seen uh compared to phones or even dslrs
where it can't capture all of that so
all this photo stacking does help I
would say if there's a beautiful moon
and we're going out somewhere and I want
to remember that I would rather have
this AI kind of faked shot than a blurry
mess like we've shown you guys over the
years with the iPhone photo or even a
pixel 5x like you see here but with that
said I just wish they wouldn't be
advertising it that much and even having
an article saying it's not putting in
fake stuff it's just really good
enhancement when in reality based on I
read a poster it is impossible to do
without AI adding things in now I will
say that I am absolutely shocked how
much detail apple is now getting out of
a 3X compared to a 10x on a Samsung
without that AI editions for example
this shot right here the pixels at 5x
and it got destroyed and this shot right
here how is a 3X camera keeping up with
the 5x pixel it's very very good
algorithms now if you guys want to see
that video I'll link it with the end
card but I want to hear your guys's
opinion how much does this really matter
do you care about Samsung faking this
and was MKBHD a little bit too nice to
see Samsung kind of downplaying it with
his video talking about this whole issue
and how he was wrong now I'm also making
a comparison with the s22 to ultra and
the 14 pro Max going against 200
megapixels against 48 megapixels both
with compressed files and using
Samsung's expert raw that gives you the
full flexibility can it really compare
to Pro raw and I think you'll be very
surprised with some of the shots
megapixels isn't always the best thing
or isn't always uh better images so make
sure you guys click that Circle above to
subscribe if you guys want to see that
and check out one of those great videos
right over there the camera comparisons
and other comparisons and I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
thank you